Before I go i couldn't leave you without
giving a few more updates on some of our
most anticipated upcoming films in january
we'll begin filming thor love and thunder
with director taika watiti and chris hemsworth
natalie portman and tessa thompson returning
and i'm pleased to confirm that academy
award-winning actor christian bale is
playing the villain gorr the god butcher thor love
and thunder releases in theaters on may 6 2022.
Happy New Year everyone this is going to be
my new marvel thor 4 video obviously they
dropped that teaser back during the big kevin
feige presentation they also made some special
announcements in the past couple of weeks it'll
also be crossing over with the loki episodes
which we're gonna see in may i will be doing
episode videos for all that stuff including the
one division episodes that start next week so be
sure to subscribe to get all those if you're brand
new to my channel we're also doing a giveaway
for disney plus subscriptions all you have to
do to enter is just be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for thor 4 on the video
taikawati released a whole bunch of teasers
an early concept art talking about the story
during 2020 in the lockdown period so i'll
include some of that in the video too there
was even the funny iron man scene that he quote
unquote accidentally leaked but that was meant
to be a big joke iron man himself is not in
the movie there was just a joke page that he
left in frame during the live stream just enough
for people to see what was on the page and during
the script there was a bunch of really terrible
dialogue about thor running into a version of
iron man seeing that he had survived the snap but
obviously that was just meant to be a joke iron
man is still supposed to be dead after the end
of avengers end game most of this video and the
biggest thing obviously is christian bale being
confirmed as gorr the god butcher i'm so happy
that they confirmed my big theory because gorr is
a really cool character and he's one of the few
marvel villains that's a big enough threat
to thor now that he's gotten all these big
upgrades thor has been confirmed as a legit god in
the mcu he got his big storm breaker upgrade and
he's in the middle of using star-lord's bowflex
to lose all that weight like you've seen chris
hemsworth posting all those workout videos taika
batidi confirmed that we would not be doing fat
thor anymore in the thor movies he's going to go
back to being the swoll version of thor that you
would expect to see but the other big change that
kevin feige announced that because they shuffled
some of the marvel phase 4 movies that also means
that they changed some of the post-credits scenes
so that it all makes sense all the post-credit
scenes the tease future films work in the right
order now so i will talk about some of the
post-credits scene changes during the video too
but just to talk about the biggest stuff first
obviously christian bale gorr the god butcher
if you haven't been reading the comics the gorr
storyline is all jason aaron the reason why that's
important for the other stuff that they're doing
with the thor 4 movie the jane foster version
of thor is because jason aaron also wrote the
mighty thor story line with jane foster's thor
but the whole thing with gorr is that he basically
goes around the marvel universe killing everyone
that's a god not just the thor characters but
anyone who can claim any sort of godhood on any
level in the mcu the reason why gorr hates gods so
much is because he used to worship them he was a
very devout person he prayed for deliverance from
suffering and plight he feels like they abandoned
him because his family died he's out for revenge
so he blames all the marvel gods for being lazy
not doing their jobs protecting their subjects
saying they don't care about us the gods don't
care about us so they should all die so in the mcu
during avengers infinity war when thanos snaps the
infinity gauntlet killing half of all life gorr
did not get snapped he survived during that five
year time span but his family did get snapped he
feels like thor the other mcu gods should have
protected them from thanos in the snap they got
into this a little bit with e tree and the dwarves
on nivel delir when he went to get stormbreaker
built peter dinklage's character e tree said that
thor was supposed to protect them from thanos you
were supposed to protect us they were attacked by
thanos when he forced them to create the infinity
gauntlet when loki was still pretending to be
odin when thor was on a walkabout and as we
learned loki really didn't do anything as king
of asgard he just sat around building statues of
himself writing those bad plays about his life
so that's why gorr wants to kill thor he blames
him for not rescuing them remember all the memes
after avengers infinity war thor should have gone
for the head that's why gorr wants to get him then
after the snap when he should have been helping
his people rebuild helping the other people of the
universe the way the other gods should have thor
completely abandoned his post like you see him
sitting there getting super fat playing fortnite
with corrigan meek the only thing he did during
that period was just sass noob bastard and drink
a whole lot of beer then after avengers end game
when they snap everyone back thor continues to
shirk his responsibilities as a legit god in the
mcu he doesn't want to be king of asgard so he
just screws off with the guardians of the galaxy
for fun and adventure so that's why gorr hates
all marvel gods and he's basically going around
at the beginning of thor 4 around the universe
killing anyone that can claim any sort of godhood
even the lesser gods even the major gods that's
why it's so relevant that the guardians of the
galaxy are a big part of the movie they're much
bigger part than i would have expected before
and most of the guardians are showing up now
confirmed to be showing up on set because
they're filming right now you may have seen the
video of chris pratt and tom holland spoiling
his involvement in the movie it was totally
hilarious i've got um guardians coming up
next year and i've got thor i'm gonna
go be in thor in australia so i'll be
traveling in australia in about a week wait
a minute did you say you're gonna be in thor
that's so crazy did it in my life
i feel like no one knew that bro
no they knew that they knew that i think they knew
that no they knew that if they didn't they know
[ __ ] well they know now chris pratt doing his
best to join the spoiler bros tom holland and mark
buffalo star-lord is technically also a god in the
marvel universe more of a demigod actually because
he's half god the son of ego the living planet
who literally called himself a god with a little g
even though he lost his powers when ego supposedly
died and he's not as powerful when he's not
touching ego's surface gorr wouldn't care about
any of those qualifiers he just said you're a god
you just made my list so you have to imagine peter
quill trying to dance his way out of that fight
and for those of you that are really hyped up
about the necrosword tycho batidi said that they
had actually already borrowed some aspects of gorr
the god butcher's necrosword when they created the
hella character in thor ragnarok this is the
hela's ability to manifest all those weapons
the blaze that just come out of nowhere the giant
spikes at the end of the movie when she's fighting
certain those were inspired visually by the
look and the feel of gorr's necrosword and
i know because of the lore behind the necrosword
and what marvel did with that recently during the
donny kate's comics run in all the spider-man
3 spider-verse multiverse easter eggs it seems
like we're getting in the confirmed tom holland
then a movie crossover that they're building up
to in the future a lot of you are now asking if
there's going to be some sort of venom easter eggs
in their interpretation of gorr in the necrosword
because in the marvel universe now the necrosword
is basically the primal symbiote it's like
a supercharged version of the venom symbiote
i think at some point eventually sony would
love to be able to build up to a null storyline
with the primal symbiotes inside the venom spinoff
movies but the thing is is that the null character
just relative to venom is kind of like a thanos
infinity gauntlet level storyline so they can't
just go straight to that right away there's still
so much other story that they have to do first
and most of what kevin feige has said about
venom mcu crossover stuff is that it'll be tom
holland's spider-man going to the venom movie not
venom coming to the mcu so just depending on how
they interpret gorr's necrosword during the movie
we'll see if there are any kind of smaller venom
easter eggs but obviously i'm not expecting
venom to show up anywhere during the movie
remember the town tonsburg where new asgard is
built that's the same town from the flashback at
the beginning of the first thor movie where they
were fighting the frost giants it's also the town
where odin hid the tesseract at the beginning of
the first captain america movie it's like odin's
favorite town marvel wrote thor into the beowulf
epic poem and inside that town tonsburg norway in
ancient times the grendel creature attacks within
the marvel universe they revealed that the grendel
creature was just the primal symbiote inhabiting
other creatures other people so it was basically
thor versus a version of venom in ancient history
but because the movie is probably only going to be
like two and a half hours long i'm only expecting
thor for to do a cliff's notes version of any
kind of big history like that in obviously gorr's
history as well the reason why the gorr story is
connected to what's happening in the mighty thor
storyline is because of all the idea of multiple
versions of thor during the gorr storyline
you have the main version of thor teaming up
with other versions of himself to defeat him just
because he's not enough by himself to defeat gorr
the big difference though is that it's actually
other versions of himself from other parts of the
timeline not from alternate universes in the way
the mcu is treating time travel in the multiverse
is they're all kind of lumping it together
using the quantum realm so time travel alternate
timelines alternate realities alternate dimensions
all kind of the same thing within the mcu the loki
series that we're going to be getting episodes for
in may after the black widow movie drops is going
to flesh out more mcu time travel in the mechanics
of these alternate timelines alternate realities
the one division episodes which we're going to
be getting really really soon is going to be the
beginning of the multiverse storyline in marvel
phase 4 scarlet witch sort of setting things off
in a big way but that series doesn't really get
into time travel that's more just about alternate
realities the reason why after avengers end game
gorr is like the next big major marvel villain
next thanos level threat is because his grand
plan is to build a bomb that will kill all marvel
gods all across the mcu all at the same time all
across time and space so it's like a version of
thanos snapping the infinity gauntlet killing a
selected half of all life except this time he's
only killing the gods but just talking about
some of the marvel phase 4 post credit scenes
because thor 4 is coming out right after doctor
strange 2 i would expect a doctor strange 2 post
credit scene with the thor characters setting at
the beginning of that movie they did the exact
same thing with the first doctor strange movie
so maybe they'll just have another funny moment
like that and because this version of loki is also
going to be in thor 4 i would also expect a loki
post credit scene at the end of that series
helping set up the beginning of thor 4 as well
there was also a really big announcement about
the future of the loki series this morning so
that's probably going to be my next video i'll
try to post that by later tonight if i can work
fast enough and also the very first episode
of marvel legends is dropping i believe at
midnight so i will do a video for that tomorrow
that's going to be sort of a prequel to the one
division episodes those will also start next week
as well so just make sure you have alerts turned
on for my channel so you don't miss any of those
videos and i'll name a giveaway winner when i post
that new loki video everyone click here for that
really big one division episode 1 scene in the
x-men stuff that they just posted and click here
for that really big deadpool 3 ryan reynolds video
that he just posted as well thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!